what's the timeline for things to get
real weird with AI and it can get weird
in interesting ways before you get to
AGI what about AI girlfriends and
boyfriends
fundamentally transforming human
relationships
I think human relationships are already
fundamentally transformed and it's
already very weird by which by which
technology points on social media
yeah
is it though isn't the fundamentals of
the core group of humans that affect
your life it's still the same your loved
ones family no I think that for instance
many people live in intentional
communities right now they're moving
around until they find people that they
can relate to when they become their
family and often that doesn't work
because it turns out that instead of
having grown networks where you get
around with the people that you grew up
with you have more transactional
relationships you shop around you have
markets for attention and pleasure and
relationships that kills the magic
somehow why is that why is the
transactional search
uh for optimizing attention allocation
of attention somehow misses the Romantic
magic of what human relations does
author question how magical was it
before was it that you just could rely
on instincts that uh used your
intuitions and you didn't need to
rationally reflect uh but once you
understand uh it's no longer magical
because you actually understand uh why
you were attracted to this person at
this age and not to that person at this
age and what the actual considerations
were that went on in your mind and what
the calculations were what what's the
likelihood that you're going to have a
sustainable relationship with this
person that this person is not going to
leave you for somebody else how are your
life trajectories are going going to
evolve and so on and when you're young
you're unable to ex duplicate all this
and you have to rely on intuitions and
instincts that in part you were born
with and also in the wisdom of your
environment that is going to give you
some kind of reflection on your choices
and many of these things are
disappearing now because uh we feel that
our parents might have no idea about how
we are living and the environments that
we go in the cultures that we grew up in
the middle use that our parents existed
in might have no ability to teach us how
to deal with this new world and for many
people that's actually true but it
doesn't mean that within one generation
we build something that is more magical
and more sustainable and More Beautiful
instead we often end up with an attempt
to produce something that looks
beautiful like I was very weirded out by
the Aesthetics of the
um Vision Pro at that by Apple and not
so much because I don't like the
technology I'm very curious about what
it's going to be like and have don't
have an opinion yet but uh the
Aesthetics of the presentation and so on
were so uncanny valley-esque to me the
characters uh being extremely plastic
living in some hypothetical
um
myth Century Furniture Museum yeah
this is uh the proliferation of
marketing teams yes but it was a CGI
generated world and with the CGI
generated well that doesn't exist and
when I complained about this uh some
friends came back to me but these are
startup Founders this is uh what they
are what they live like in Silicon
Valley and I try to tell them no and
know lots of people in Silicon Valley
this is not what people are like there's
still people they're still human beings
so the the
grounding of physical reality somehow is
important too
um in culture and so basically what's
absent in this thing is culture there is
a simulation of culture an attempt to
replace Culture by catalog by some kind
of
um aesthetic optimization that is not
the result of having a sustainable life
a sustainable human relationships with
houses that work for you and
um a mode of living that works for you
in which this product
um these glasses fit in naturally and I
I guess that's also why so many people
are weirded out about the product
because they don't know how is this
actually going to fit into my life into
my human relationships because the way
in which it was presented in these
videos didn't seem to be credible